was tun 1 rausholen wir haben so kann es
mehr heraus und das nennen wir fragen
leute sind also fragen drin das rote
sind unverschämte fragen wo soll ich
dann versuchen wir mit dem gesalzen den
finger in die wunde zu fassen bei den
roten ja hallo
die grünen sind dann die salbe die ware
anschließend alles leider musste erst
ein rotes aufmachen jannis
da freuen wir uns über den sehr darüber
14 jahre als nachwuchs karlo rieth ist
wann ist ihre karriere endlich aus den
kinderschuhen raus das ist eine sehr
gute frage
dafür gibt sogar eine ganz simple
begründung im kabarett bereich ist man
eigentlich bis 49 nachwuchs ab 50 ist
man erwachsen
vorher nicht woher kommt ja weil das
durchschnittsalter der real
existierenden in der öffentlichkeit
wahrgenommen kabarettisten zu 95 prozent
über 60 liegt okay so eine salbe
freue mich schon
wobei ich die roten natürlich fast
spannender für ja noch mehr da sie
finden dass die ehe ein
überholtes modell ist
warum enthalten sie sich der frauenwelt
so vor
dazu kann ich nur sagen
viele frauen werden berichten können
dass ich mich der frauenwelt nicht
vorenthalten möchte dazu nicht weiter
etwas sagen einfach nur aus betroffenen
schutz
jetzt wiederholt muss ja nicht alle
machen oder nur ein teil du kannst wie
du möchtest ich kann zwar hilfreich aber
toll wir haben schon leute die haben
versucht aufzuhören konnten aber ich
konnte nicht weil es ist so interessant
etwas was nur miteinander
aha das schön was machen sie zuerst auto
kaufen oder heiraten ganz entschieden
auto kaufen
weil ich ein tourbegleiter habe der
fährt leidenschaftlich gerne und sehr
gut da kann das auto dann fahren
so wächst worden
mal sehen was wir denn hier
das ist schwer auszumachen immer für so
unpraktische menschen wie mich wie haben
sie den absprung von klassenclown zum
comedy star und kabarett der kabarettist
da hatten wir die belehrung jaja die
eben noch keine terminologie noch nicht
klar wie haben sie den absprung vom
klassenclown zum comedy star geschafft
sich lange harte arbeit
durch
immer wieder sich selber in frage
stellen und viele harte kleinkunstbühnen
mit sehr wenig zuschauer wie kommt man
auf den boden zurück wenn man mit 14
schon mal bei harald schmidt gesessen
habe da gibt es ja viele die drehen
durch und denken ja ja das habe ich das
habe ich auch getan ich habe ja dann
gesehen wohin das 1 führte nämlich zum
privatradio nach freiburg zum praktikum
auf die straße umfragen machen und
fragen was halten sie eigentlich vom
wetter da wird man doch schnell wieder
demütig ja war nicht deine erfüllung
nein überhaupt nicht es war eine
wichtige epoche aber erfüllung wäre nun
wirklich der falsche begriff
das war der antrieb dann philosophie zu
studieren
genau das ja natürlich antrieb war schon
dass das all das dass das was einen
umgibt die menschen darum geben weil zu
verstehen ihr spezialgebiet ist das
passiv ihren anderer personen ist ihre
eigene persönlichkeit zu uninteressant
nein natürlich nicht die jetzt gefühlte
drei stunden in diesem interview
bewiesen habe
so
grün jetzt wo ich finde gar nicht dass
die grünen einen sog auch pinseln ich
finde auch nicht dass die roten so hart
sind aber
das ist alles findet so im
relativ doch noch gut klimatisierten
raum statt wie schaffen sie es ständig
neue facetten an einer rolle zu finden
durch das studium der rolle durch
intensives studium des originals durch
wach bleiben für veränderungen
entwicklungen die die figur durch macht
durch eine gewisse
wachheit sensibilität
und rot mensch noch zwei nachdem es
wieder spannend jetzt kommt
wahrscheinlich jetzt kommt die ganze
härte
gibt walter bösartigkeit und ich habe
schon gelesen und es war eine lange
frage
dass das war ja fast klar dass die frage
kommt da folgen sehr
sie haben ihr studium abgebrochen und
auf der bühne schlüpfen sie ständig in
andere rollen können sie auch konsequent
sein ja natürlich und wie ich bin ja
bin ja sehr konsequent weil das studium
abzubrechen in dem moment wo es wirklich
nicht mehr geht ist ja die höchste
konsequenz
die es gibt und
auf der bühne schlüpfe ich in andere
rollen aber es hat immer eine funktion
in sofern es ist nie selbstzweck was er
selbst weg wäre wenn ich jetzt fünf
minuten als grönemeyer
umgetextet singen würde weil ich es
lustig finde das wäre selbst weg aber
weil es alles kein selbstzweck ist hat
es in sich auch eine konsequenz aber ein
studium abbrechen da denkt man doch
wahrscheinlich eigentlich nicht weil die
frage ist ja nicht was man davon ob man
da jetzt den abschluss hat und was da
draußen steht bayer philosophie
philosophie und erstens macht er die
mehrheit keine abschluss zweitens ist es
eigentlich als kabarettist kann man
nicht ankommen sagen ich habe studium
abgeschlossen das geht nicht und die
frage ist nicht ob man am schluss diesen
wunsch diesen abschluss in der hand hat
und die frage ist was was aus diesem
studium was an inhalten man sozusagen
für sich lebendig halten kann oder am
leben halten kann und ob man sich damit
beschäftigt ob das irgendwie nachwirkt
und ich kann von mir sagen dass ich bis
heute da sehr viel lese sehr
interessiert bin dass ich dadurch mehr
mitgenommen habe als viele die ich
beobachtet habe und nach dem studium
drei jahre danach wieder getroffen habe
und gedacht habe also dass die dieses
studium gemacht haben merkt man nicht
mehr gut wenn sie hegel im urlaub lesen
ich meine ja das ist schon getan da gibt
es nicht viele da gibt sich viele aber
es ist doch immer wieder spannend so
was kommt jetzt eine rote damit ich zum
schluss eine grüne habe und noch mal
spaß hat im leben in der schulzeit haben
sie ihre äußerlichen defizite mit humor
wettgemacht
finden sie sich immer noch so hässlich
nein
nicht mehr so wie früher zum glück aber
phasenweise schon also ich nehme mich
selbst eigentlich nur in extremen war
entweder im absoluten größen waren oder
im totalen selbstzweifel
also adonis oder laut klöckner von notre
dame oder um
midway weg zu sprechen
verachtung für die anderen selbst hast
für sich selbst
aber nicht durchzuhalten
das haben aber echt aussehen ich ja das
wirklich ja im kern habe ich das in
kärnten ist aber schon ich hab mal von
feuerstein gehört was ich für mich
absolut übernehmen kann der immer gesagt
hat die triebfeder war immer hass auf
die menschen tiefe liebe zum publikum
das ist glaube ich genau das was es
ausmacht letztlich was ein produkt hält
wurde ihnen die fähigkeit zu parodieren
in die wiege gelegt ich glaube letztlich
ja das talent ja also vieles von dem
heute ist natürlich auch arbeit vieles
von dem was man heute als ergebnis sieht
aber das grundlegende talent ja von wem
haben sie
sowohl von meiner mutter als auch von
meinem vater
vor allem von meiner mutter aber
offenbar
wir haben ja das könnte also gar nicht
anders kommen super vielen dank gerne